Before we close, let's recap
really quick how Dyna-Q works.
So, we start with straight,
regular Q-Learning here and
then we add three new components.
The three components are,
we update models of T and
R, then we hallucinate an experience.
And update our Q table.
Now we may repeat this many times,
in fact maybe hundreds of times,
until we're happy.
Usually, it's 1 or 200 here.
Once we've completed those,
we then return back up to the top and
continue our interaction
with the real world.
The reason Dyna-Q is useful is that
These experiences with the real
world are potentially very expensive and
these hallucinations can be very cheap.
And when we iterate doing many of them,
we update our Q table much more quickly.